nos dicen que hdx es igual a menos la
raíz cúbica de 3x menos 6 y a todo eso
le sumamos 12 y queremos averiguar cuál
es la función inversa de h
déjame notarlo lo que quiero saber es
cuál es la función inversa de hdx y como
siempre te invito a que pause el vídeo y
veas y tú puedes resolverlo por tu
cuenta muy bien quiero que recuerdes lo
siguiente una función te lleva de un
dominio a un rango y en vídeos
anteriores enfatizamos que la función
inversa lo que hace es llevarte de
regreso es decir vas a ir del punto del
rango al punto del dominio donde
empezaste entonces una manera de pensar
esto es que queremos agarrar una
expresión que deshaga cualquier cosa que
haga esta función o te lleve de regreso
al punto inicial en el dominio y para
encontrarla lo que voy a hacer primero
es renombrar esta función como bien y es
igual a hdx es lo que voy a hacer y es
más déjeme escribirlo aquí james va a
ser igual a menos la raíz cúbica la raíz
cúbica de 3x menos 6 ya esto le sumamos
12 ok esto nos da una cierta jane y
puedes ver a está bien como un miembro
del rango en términos claro de lo que
nos da nuestra entrada es decir en
términos de un miembro del dominio pero
nosotros queremos ir en sentido
contrario entonces lo que podemos hacer
es intentar resolver esta función para x
despejar a x y así vamos a tener una
expresión que sea una función de james
porque al despejar a equis vamos a tener
a x igualada a esa función y esa sería
la manera de obtener la función inversa
o dicho otra manera el mapeo inverso
ahora bien otra manera de hacerlo
sería intercambiar en este momento xy
james y luego resolver para ella pero yo
siento que es un poco menos intuitivo
que la otra idea para obtener la función
inversa entonces simplemente resolvamos
para x bien lo primero que se me ocurre
es que podemos restar 12 de ambos lados
de esta expresión para eliminar este 12
que tenemos aquí así que de este lado
voy a restar 12 lo voy a poner así voy a
restar 12 y de este lado también voy a
restar 12 así que estos dos se van a ir
y que me va a quedar bueno del lado
izquierdo me va a quedar ye menos 12 y
en menos 12 esto va a ser igual a menos
la raíz cúbica la raíz cúbica de 3x
menos seis muy bien estos dos se van
ahora este signo negativo siento que lo
necesitábamos quitar así que para
quitarlo qué te parece si multiplico
todo por menos uno
voy a multiplicar este lado por menos
uno
voy a multiplicar todo esto por menos 1
por menos 1 para eliminar de una vez
este signo negativo y bueno menos 1 x
menos 12 eso es exactamente lo mismo que
12 menos
james y del lado derecho este signo
negativo se van menos x menos me da más
y simple y sencillamente me quedo con la
raíz cúbica de 3x menos 6 y ahora lo que
voy a hacer a continuación te desparece
un poco aterrador pero no lo es tanto lo
único que voy a hacer es elevar al cubo
a ambos lados de esta ecuación voy a
elevar al cubo la parte izquierda y la
parte derecha y bueno realmente no es
tan aterrador porque no voy a expandir
este cubo que me va a quedar me va a
quedar solamente 12 - jane esto elevado
al cubo esto debe de ser igual a quien
aquí el cubo con la raíz cúbica se van
porque cuando elevas una raíz cúbica al
cubo solamente te quedas con la parte de
arriba
qué es 3 x 6 muy bien y queremos
resolver para x así que ya va a ser muy
fácil qué te parece si sumamos 6 de
ambos lados sumamos 6 de ambos lados que
voy a obtener bueno del lado izquierdo
voy a obtener 12 - bien esto elevado al
cubo más 6 y del lado derecho voy a
obtener estos 2 evans 3x ahora qué te
parece si divido todo entre 3 esta parte
la voy a dividir entre 3 y esta parte la
voy a dividir entre 3 de tal manera que
estos dos se van y ahora sí me va a
quedar simplemente que x va a ser igual
a 12 - james esto elevado al cubo más 6
más
esto dividido entre 3 ahora una manera
de ver esto es que si tienes un miembro
del rango james entonces este te va a
llevar de regreso a la equis que tuviera
llevado a ese miembro del rango game
entonces esta es la función inversa por
lo tanto lo puedes escribir como h
inverso de james h inverso de james esta
función es la función 12 menos esto
elevado al cubo más 6 está dividido
entre 3 y de hecho no forzosamente tiene
que ser james como lo vimos en los otros
vídeos puede ser cualquier cosa puede
ser no sé se me ocurre en estrella y
decir h inverso de estrella dejar
ponerlo así esto es lo mismo que bueno
12 - estrella esto elevado al cubo más 6
todo esto dividido entre 3 o también lo
podemos nombrar como h
de equis y ahora ponemos como entrada a
nuestra equis la función que es 12 menos
x
esto elevado al cubo más 6 y todo esto
dividido entre 3 y bueno tal vez esto te
parece un poco confuso porque ahora en
teoría x estaría siendo considerada como
un miembro del rango pero de cualquier
manera podemos llamar a la entrada de la
función prácticamente como tú quieras
lo importante es que aquí lo tienes esta
es nuestra función inversa que
esencialmente deshace lo que hacen
nuestra función original